[Music]
let's put you guys into a scenario okay
hiya you're a cool karate guy already
you have stolen a u-haul truck oh [ __ ]
that's very practical to be honest and
police are
are after you not practical because it's
it's pretty slow i'll steal a different
clock yeah what are you going to do
drive that's interesting
anybody else hot take hot take
the plates yeah just go to another
u-haul rental location and try to hide
there for a second as i find a different
vehicle duh next question that's dope
pull it into a u-haul location that's
full of other u-hauls and then crawl out
and then hopefully it gets all mixed up
and then you run some rock that's really
smart he should have done that didn't do
that
no he just drove up no he uh he decided
that he was going to call police
dispatch and ask them to please stop
chasing him
that's pretty funny
that's pretty funny i respect it
he's courteous you know he's just like
hey i don't want to you know do this
whole chase thing maybe they give like
creativity points or something like that
yeah that's that's pretty good he's very
honorable i feel like he stop please can
you please stop like seriously
what did he what did he do like other
than steal a u-haul just told you oh
that's all that that's what brian
laundry should have done you should have
called the [ __ ]
can you guys just not look for me please
like not did i just cut it out i just
like the brazenness of that
i was just like hey can you guys please
not chase me right now how long was he
getting chased for do you know they
don't say how they said it happened at 1
40 a.m if we try to carry the cops
excuse me
it's really annoying or if he at least
like call the fake crime nearby
like if he drives by mcdonald's like i'm
calling for mcdonald's on whatever
whatever street they're robbing me right
now they'll have like weapons or
whatever they could maybe hopefully
distract or dilute the force maybe dude
if brian landry was like
i'm in a u-haul truck and then he drove
to a u-haul yard i think that's a really
good idea yeah he would have [ __ ]
which is trucks dude uh [ __ ]
boom
[Laughter]
over dude [ __ ] idiot what a [ __ ]
dude that's why you have to go to a
tunnel with another car and then the
time you park your car do you hold there
and you go into a different car and then
you go out like that or in like heist
movies
yeah they take the truck that they're
driving it or whatever and then they go
into a bigger car
oh in the trunk and then they close it
you take your u-haul right off a cliff
but then a c-130 comes up
you just happen to
get right into it like a pot you're
dropping into a pocket yeah and then the
c-130 goes into [ __ ] nasa station
oh [ __ ] that's fascinating no way that's
him you whisper to like a butterfly and
then you fall down and the eagle catches
you yeah and then you're like okay how
much did it cost to steal this u-haul
truck guys
wow that's way more than the u-haul what
are we doing
i'm not going to business you could have
bought one we're the negative dude they
saw these
u-hauls are like 20 bucks a day huh yeah
man you know people are doing that now
to just do a rent-a-car because it's way
cheaper especially in hawaii yeah do
people are doing that people are doing
it to live in right now like
yeah people because of like covet and
money struggles people are are renting
u-hauls and they're just driving them up
into the mountains and sleeping in the
back sleeping in the back are they just
stealing them yeah [ __ ] yeah of course
wait wait wait twenty dollars perfect
in town but then they charge you per
mile [ __ ]
that's like if you don't drive because
like i ran a u-haul recently to pick up
a sofa and i paid 100 bucks so i go to
silver lake so maybe i did i did it the
wrong way obviously did you get the 1995
deal or whatever i think i think so yeah
did you get the the crate what's called
the [ __ ] the dollar i also got the
dollar as well so maybe they added like
a bunch of blankets
i did they didn't charge for the blanket
you had a ramp yeah it came with a ramp
oh was it a ramp or was it what yeah did
they add all these fees on you yeah you
probably pay for insurance dude it was
just like the normal one that like you
pull out and then it comes down is it
like 5 pm to 5 pm or did you go like
half day dude you guys know u-haul bro
like i obviously [ __ ] up because i did
it the wrong way but i'm going to ask
you guys next time for the u-haul hockey
well you didn't [ __ ] up that much
because you can get caught by the cops
that's true i didn't do anything illegal
oh i see
does he have a reason why he stole the
u-haul once again i'm asking more
questions
it doesn't say it's just well they
actually it actually says that he did
try one maneuver it says that um he did
that stop thing where he stops and the
deputies get out and they come up to the
car
dude and grant them auto that worked are
you serious is there a video of this i
want to know i wish you well so they're
like stop and then they're like all
right we could surround him and he goes
fake get out [ __ ]
like you get 0 to 60 in like 20 minutes
what's what's the top speed on a u-haul
bro that's like probably like 60 60 285
that's crazy probably like 65. i love
watching police chase videos because you
could literally hear their
decision-making should i make a left
should make them not make a right oh
[ __ ] i [ __ ] went over the curve oh
[ __ ] and they smashed another car you
could just see them going like this they
make a left swimming right oh [ __ ] i
went straight why'd i do that
t-bone
they keep distance though because
they're afraid of like
scaring the driver yeah spook at the
driver why are they chasing them at all
on them just chasing them just keep it
just to keep them just to keep the tail
on them if they need to grab them but
it's like this and then they'll do the
whole pit maneuver if it's safe oh yeah
i've done that i just put need for speed
dude
i know that [ __ ] yeah i get a burnout
costs so much
what is it
well even if the chopper is on every
chase there has to be a cop close by so
that if he does stop they can come up
they run out yeah or they could surround
them dude because i watched the movie
heat i'm like dude just drive to the
airport cause then the choppers can't
trace you because they're getting into
the airspace airspace dude that's
actually legit what do you think would
happen if he drove to area 51
and he tried to drive into area 51 would
he get shot first for sure and are the
choppers allowed to go into that
i don't think the choppers would go in
because
this was about to get blown up because
he's probably not like inching and
slowly where they have time to like
react it's just like this was driving
him we're gonna stop his ass i feel like
the chopper will be flying towards area
51 and like hey you guys got it
yes and they're just gonna pull back and
wait to see what the [ __ ] happened
[Applause]
remember back in the day everyone's um
like
escape plan was go to mexico like every
time across the border dude yeah like a
high-speed pursuit or whatever every in
the movies it was always go to mexico
right do you think that actually worked
back then i feel like it did work
because it's like the moment they uh you
get across borders they don't chase you
anymore no but like while the police is
like [ __ ]
right all this [ __ ] right they're on
your tail
can you
have you seen that successfully done
where they can cross the border without
any stopping i love the idea that the
police are on you and choppers are on
you and then mexico's like hurry get the
[ __ ] yeah right come on
no no there's
i feel like if you were smart you
wouldn't go like so you know like the
border between um
mexico and the u.s where san diego is
like one yeah like you wouldn't go
through there you would drive through
somewhere else where there isn't like a
million cars and i mean where the great
wall is yes where the great wall is yes
i do know the way that it is sounds like
you've done this like even in the in the
movie sicario they can't just go across
the border like because you [ __ ] up
relations and then you can start like
like countries are just waiting for
reasons to go to war with each other
unless you bring a particular unit uh
you're right that's the whole premise
cardio having that one chick on because
of the jurisdiction problem or something
yeah and then they still got into a
firefight like on the freeway that's
true yeah it gets so delicious that was
a very cool scene though yeah
like blue streak
i'm a federal rally i'm not a rally
[Laughter]
martin lawrence dude he's so underrated
dude i love he doesn't make movies
anymore huh what you love here
she's so good
i haven't seen him in ages oh he did bad
boys three didn't he yeah
was that any good i don't know when did
that come out martin lawrence is one of
the funniest he's so flying dude you
guys wear black knight
one of the best premises ever dude the
idea for that movie is [ __ ]
ridiculous so good
and only martin lawrence he works at
like a medieval times type place right
and then he sees a necklace in the
pool or whatever and he tries it he
falls in but he falls through a
portal was the first black knight people
in medieval times
the place where he portaled through
is like
so like where they built that medieval
times was where this castle used to be
or whatever yeah
in america
like all of a sudden you know it's still
in america too it's the best dude his
old show martin was so good too
i like how he played the shaniqua or
like the neighbor and
then he played all the characters his
best movie was blue streak though that
movie
that movie is so [ __ ] good i used to
watch that movie like i don't even know
how like how many times a week i watched
that's the one where he would watch that
and wherever he hit it it ended up being
a police station right yeah that's right
you put the jewels he has to pretend to
be a cop and then he he starts getting
put on cases yeah yeah because he's a
super cop
he turns out to be a great cop
that [ __ ] was tight what's the movie
where he was uh
he gets
beat by another cop because a cop
thought there was a oh there was a b he
was trying to hit the b
but then uh the survey the civilian
footage shows like police brutality
so that cop gets fired and then now uh
but martin lawrence becomes a security
guard and they end up being partners he
goes [ __ ] you do you guys remember i
remember that yeah i don't remember what
it was called it's really it's really
absurd yeah that's a [ __ ] funny ass
setup yeah that goes to his car and he
goes oh [ __ ] i left my key's in there
again he's like [ __ ] whatever and then
the cop he sees of course the black guy
next to a car and he's like oh this
motherfucker's trying to steal it
and mine's like no no those are my keys
those are my keys and they go step back
in the car sir and he goes oh [ __ ]
there's a bee i'm allergic to bees he's
like starts whacking him and then there
was a civilian
[ __ ] [ __ ] so stupid
they're both security cops yeah they're
gonna be secure security guards together
and they end up changing the force
[Music]